so this year i've already made a video
on halloween in general
i've also made a video on vampires as
being
a monstrous version of the hierarchy
and so based on the poll that i put out
on twitter to find out which monsters
people wanted
it seems like the imps and goblins and
that kind of monster won out which is
good because
in a way it will show us the flip side
of the vampire
if the vampire is the monster of
hierarchy
then these imps these goblins you know
these pucks
these types of uh um these types of
earthy creatures
are in fact a symbol of the opposite it
could be the
symbolism of the earth we could call it
or the symbolism of potentiality
so we're gonna look at that and see what
we can get out of it
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
so it's a little difficult to separate
some of these creatures
because although in some stories they
will have separate characteristics
um trolls imps hobgoblins pucks
what are the other words but even things
like trolls
uh like fairies or elves sometimes take
on the characteristics
of these kind of earthy creatures for
example the elf
in northern mythology you know this the
the type that we find in tolkien
is quite different than the christmas
elf for example
the christmas elf acts more like a robin
goodfellow or a puck
or a hobgoblin then they do act as
those elves so we have to try to be
careful about the naming and rather look
at the characteristics
and see what they show us and in terms
of symbolism
this symbolism is going to help people
also understand
how sometimes the same symbols can
manifest
in different characteristics opposites
of the same
category and so in these kind of earthy
monsters what you get
is the symbolism of uh
the the harnessing of potentiality you
could call it
and so you can see the good side and the
negative
side of that you know the harnessing of
that which is still
in darkness you could call it something
like that that which is still in
potentiality that would distill in the
earth
all of these are related and so these
types of monsters
they'll you know for example the gnomes
uh we know
the the gnomes and the trolls and all
these types of creatures
often they are seen as uh the dwarves
especially you know
in traditional mythology they're seen as
being miners
people who are underground in caves
we see in um in the the seven dwarves of
snow white for example we see an example
of the dwarves
that are working and mines and so the
dwarf working in a mine
is there to find the treasures which are
hidden
in the darkness and to make use of them
you see that also
in this idea that uh
these uh these creatures often they are
the dwarves for example
are known for smithing and so smithing
is also related to that
it's kind of this capacity to take the
metal from the ground
and to harness it in order to create a
form of technology
now technology itself is related to this
darkness you could say i've talked about
this quite a few times
when i've explained that technology in
the bible
for example comes from the uh
the descendants of cain in greek
mythology
uh smithing and weapons and that kind of
technology
is made by uh hephaestus this
kind of deformed half this deformed god
that is tossed out of olympus
so there's a relationship between the
darkness on the edge
and technology because
it's it's it's we use technology to
protect ourselves from
that darkness so we gather the darkness
i've always talked about the idea of
death turning against death we gather
the darkness we gather that potential to
build
walls to make weapons to create things
which will uh which will hold back
the the darkness so that's what you see
in a lot of these
monsters and what happens is that you
end up seeing the
positive side and the negative side in
the positive side you have
these stories of what we'd called
household spirits or household monsters
like uh like hobgoblins and robin
goodfellows
we see that story particularly one of
the stories that has remained very
popular until today is the idea of the
shoemaker and the elves
so in that story the shoemaker goes to
sleep and
during while he is sleeping there's work
which is
being done when he wakes up in the
morning then the work is already done
and there are many stories of that type
of creature pucks and robin goodfellows
that will do household chores
while it's darkness and then when you
wake up there are the household chores
and all you need
is to maybe put out a little bit of food
in order for
this creature to continue but you have
to be careful
not to offend it or actually you also
have to be careful not
to praise it too much so for example in
the story of
the shoemaker and the elves the elves
decides that he's going to stay awake
instead of letting the elves
instead of letting the potential do its
job instead of letting
the elves do their work he decides to
spy on them
at night and to to to watch them and to
figure out what they're doing
and because of that he has this idea
that he wants to thank them
and in thanking them he creates new
clothing for them
and in creating new clothing for them
the elves cease to do
their work now what is that
relating to you can really understand it
as
the the power of the implicit there are
some things
which function implicitly in the way
that we
that we work sometimes it can be for
example
a a good example which is a good example
that we could use is for
is the idea that let's say you um
say you're a man and you meet a woman
and then all of a sudden
this the the woman or the man that said
the man is
attracted to the woman and
the you know the man doesn't want to
talk about it for whatever reason maybe
he's married maybe
she's married or maybe i don't know
she's a nun or whatever reason
the the or they work together and they
don't want to complicate things
and so there is this implicit thing
which sets itself up
and the implicit thing will create a
dynamic which will
possibly work to the advantage of one of
those
people maybe for the woman it will
actually work to her advantage
so she can actually get advantage from
something which is hidden
and implicit which is kind of under the
under the rug you could say
but we'll still make it that that man
for example
will do special favors for her will um
you know will want to do a little more
in order to help
the woman that he finds attractive and
this
continues to function all the time that
it's implicit
now if ever you put clothes
on it if ever you dress it up and all of
a sudden the man decides
that okay he's had enough of this
implicit kind of thing
he decides that for whatever reason he's
going to declare
his love or in another way
the lady wants to call it out and wants
to
point out this dynamic wants to point
out the fact that this man
is attracted to her to him or to people
around
in order to kind of make it public and
so what that's going to do
is that's going to cease it from working
as soon as the man declares his feelings
for the woman
all of a sudden uh whatever advantage
the woman was getting from this
situation
is going to be put in the spotlight and
if she reacts negatively
if she offends the the
if she offends the man then she's going
to stop
receiving that benefit and the strange
thing which
is probably something i shouldn't
shouldn't say but the strange thing is
that even if she acknowledges the man
and let's say
she ends up marrying him there is
something
of the power of that implicit dynamic
which
will go away the the
the type of actions that a man will pose
for a woman that he finds attractive but
that he's not in a couple with
a woman he's trying to seduce but not
too much uh will be
far will be something that will actually
somewhat cease to disappear when that
couple is married
sorry to announce that to a lot of you
single folks but that's how it works and
it goes the other way as well the same
for a woman
who is trying to seduce a man once that
implicit
uh react that implicit game goes away
then all of a sudden the uh some of the
benefits of it will disappear uh the
the advantages that come from being
implicit there are other advantages
which which come with a formal
relationship but
that type of uh implicit work
you would call it work in the dark will
go away
so that is a way to understand that how
these types of monsters represent
the implicit represent things that are
in darkness still
things that aren't quite actualized that
aren't quite
out in the world that's why like i said
they represent technology that's also
why they
are some sometimes often they're
represented as
being mischievous as well because
you know that is the thing about
something which is still
in darkness is that we don't know what
it's going to do when it comes out in
the light
you can see that in terms of technology
you know when we
put a technology out into the world we
often don't see the
unintended consequences of that
technology and that can be viewed as a
form of mischief
you could imagine something like that
the
the dwarves who secretly designed the
automobile
while it was still implicit and revealed
that automobile to uh
to the to men um they were secretly
joking they were laughing in their
beards because
although the man only could see the
positive aspect of this
automobile that would you know would
connect them and help them to
to traverse long and distant uh
trips they didn't realize that the that
the automobile would
ultimately be one of the factors that
would completely destroy
society in terms of communities by
creating these cities with malls on the
one end and
in all these houses where you work a
half an hour that way and
and you go to to you go to church 40
minutes that way
and you end up moving around without
interacting with the people near to you
and so that is the mischief which comes
from the implicit
as it is made explicit um
so you can see the different aspects of
this this kind of
things coming from the earth and what
they do one of the things that can
happen is
also a a type of obsession
when we think about the treasure which
comes from the implicit
in terms of money money is complicated
and
uh gold is a complicated symbolism
because on the one hand gold
can represent glory uh but on the other
hand gold can also represent
potentiality and it's the same with
money money is a complicated thing
because it's actually
it's a it is in some respects it is
potentiality
that is it only has value to the extent
that it can be
traded for something else that is useful
gold for example in itself
is it's becoming useful now because of
of technology but let's say in the
ancient world it was useful for making
jewelry
it was useful for doing that type of
stuff for ornamenting for
creating beauty creating glory but in
itself you couldn't make a sword out of
uh or a plowshare or anything that you
actually use
out of gold because it was too soft and
so that is also the idea of money and so
the notion of these monsters that are
obsessed with
gold or silver obsessed with money in
the sense of this
potential value is something that we see
coming
in the stories over and over again
and if in the video that i made about uh
about uh vampires i put a a quote by
karl marx
to show you that you know karl marx he
he uh he was a kind of satanic prophet
in the sense that
he really had an intuition of what
things were it's just that his intuition
was kind of upside down
and he wanted this power of darkness to
rise up and take over the the hierarchy
and so
let me read a um
so karl marx says in the signs that
bewilder the middle class the
aristocracy and the poor prophets of
regression
we do recognize our brave friend robin
goodfellow
the old mole that can work in the earth
so fast that worthy pioneer
the revolution and he sees these goblins
these imps and goblins and monsters
rising up
uh as an image of his revolution and so
he wasn't completely
naive about what was going on he he
actually had quite a
weird prophetic understanding of the
world it's just that it was quite upside
down
um and so in that sense you can
understand
what these let's say earthy monsters
are representing and why if you look at
different traditions these types of
monsters like sometimes they're they're
called
fairies um but they're fairies in the
sense that or trolls
they're they're fairies in the sense
that they are related to the land or to
a place
they're kind of like the spirit of the
land itself
rather than and so you have to be
careful when you
build on this that you don't bother the
spirit of the land
that you don't uh offend this
uh the spirit of what's hidden there and
you can understand it in that sense it's
like you don't actually know
what let's say tilling a certain land
or uh building houses on a certain in a
certain place
will give what it will produce in the
future
and so if you offend the spirit of the
land
then that action that you're taking on
the land whether it's building or
doing whatever will possibly turn
against you
and will create more mischief than it
does anything positive
um and so what's important when i talk
about the kind of duality
you can see that on the one hand these
kind of impish
earth monsters they are the source
of a lot of technology of smithing like
i said mining
all of this which is related to
technology but on the other hand they
are
also the negative side of technology the
let's say also the breakdown of
technology
we see a recent version of that of
course in gremlins this
this little monster that appeared during
i think it was during world war ii that
it appeared
um this idea of when a all of a sudden
they had these
war machines that had technology
airplanes tanks
all these mechan mechanized um
war machines which before were were not
as present
and so the idea that there are these
these types of
goblin creatures which are the cause of
their breakdown
or the cause of the accidents which are
related
to um to these kind of machines and this
kind of weaponry
um is very interesting because i like i
said you can see both sides you can see
how
they are the cause but they are also the
cause of the breakdown they're
there or you could really just see it in
the sense of the positive aspect
and the negative aspect of trusting in
this potentiality which is not yet
explicit
so i hope this makes sense i am i am
going to continue with these patron only
videos
and like you can see like what i just
did i'm going to try to always take it
one level further for you guys that are
supporting me because i know
that most of you will be following me
more attentively and will understand
some of this stuff a little more than
those that casually watch the videos
so uh please write down in the comments
uh your interactions your ideas about
about these things because i just want
to keep ramping it up as we continue
so that these patron only videos will be
even more focused on symbolism itself
trying to help you understand and see
those structures as best as we can so
thanks for your support guys and i will
see you
soon